من الجوهر في السباق
لتلقيح أكبر عدد ممكن من الأشخاص ، هناك
أدلة جديدة مقلقة على أن فيروس كوفيد
يمكن أن يؤثر على
وظائف دماغك على المدى الطويل.
يمكن أن يسبب ضررًا
للدماغ من خلال تلف الأوعية الدموية من
خلال الالتهاب من خلال السكتات الدماغية
ونقص الأكسجين ،
ولكن الآن هناك المزيد من الأدلة الجديدة
والمزيد من المعلومات ماذا يمكنك أن تخبرنا
بريانا هناك الكثير من الأدلة الآن على
أن الأطباء قد
صاغوا بالفعل مصطلحًا جديدًا يسمى النواة و
إنها تعني
الاعتلال الدماغي المرتبط بـ covid19 وما فعلوه في
هذه الدراسة ،
هذه دراسة صغيرة من
مستشفى واحد في فرنسا
وقاموا بفحص حوالي 80 مريضًا يعانون
من رغبة شديدة
في معظمهم لم يكن لديهم هذا ولكن
بعضهم فعلوه ودعونا  ألقِ نظرة على
بعض الأعراض التي وجدوها في
هؤلاء
المرضى ، فهؤلاء هم مرضى
كانوا مصابين بفيروس كوفيد -19
وكانوا يعانون من  عندما رأوا أشياء مثل
اضطرابات الحركة مثل النوبات
، كانوا يرون تمايلًا في الرأس ، كانوا
يرون أن التفكك
يمثل تفككًا بدلاً من ذلك ، وبعبارة أخرى
، لم يكونوا مثبطين
كما يتوقع المرء عادةً أن يكون الشخص
كذلك ، وبعبارة أخرى ليس
شيئًا جيدًا مرة أخرى.  دراسة صغيرة
جدًا ويحتاجون إلى إجراء المزيد من الدراسات.سؤال
كبير آخر هو هل
تختفي هذه الأعراض
عندما يختفي الطمع عندما
يتعافى الفيروس ويخرج الشخص
من المستشفى ،
هل يختفي هذا وهناك الكثير من
المخاوف الآن
أشتهي منذ فترة طويلة أن هناك
آثارًا عصبية للطمع الطويل ،
لذا فهناك مخاوف من أن بعض هذه السلوكيات
قد لا تختفي عندما يختفي الفيروس
بريانا